s'il avait concrétisé son premier rêve
jo wilfried tsonga aurait peut-être été
footballeur vu sa taille en mètre 83 à
seulement 14 ans le basket aussi lui
tendait les bras mais c'est finalement
sur des cours qu'il balade sa grande
carrure et qu'il excelle à jouer au foot
et donc j'ai foot on gagne arrière et au
tennis sur quelque chose au jeu suivant
cinq ans si bien commencée que joe
collectionne les titres le tournoi
international de nouméa la semaine
dernière qui fait du sarthois la vedette
du quotidien les nouvelles calédoniennes
mais il est aussi devenu champion de
france minimes à roland-garros et
champion du monde par équipe
c'est vrai que c'est pas vu un seul coup
toute façon nous jo on l'a vu grandir un
tout petit manifesté déjà des qualités
qui laissait penser qu'il errait quand
même un peu loin prends les choses comme
elles viennent
cela qui l'a jamais free mais le fait de
gagner tel ou tel depuis tout petit a
jamais jamais pour leurs jo a repris le
chemin des cours scolaires et de tennis
au creps de poitiers avant les
etats-unis en décembre où il tentera
d'ajouter un déjà bien joli palmarès un
titre de champion du monde individuel